こんにちは工房者大好きパズル社長ですてくらあの僕今までですねなんか子育てたり
よしよしとするペット型のお茶とかでよく遊んできたんですけども
今回すごいおもちゃを見つけてみましたこちら
うあああーーーーっっっいつも桜
をまずパッケージモンスターモンスターと言っていいんですかね
だから富山パッケージなんともうしたらもう難題が書いてあるんですよこれどういう
ことかと言いますとこの日ずもちゃん
がっするんですよいやーすごい強い今までいろんな子育てペット芸能図鑑を見てきたん
ですけども
チンカスローさん見たことないんですよこのマルコいつからこうなってこうなってくる
んですよやばくないですか
僕が釣った時に混信がするペットいたら絶対買ってますからね
では開けていきますよと言いたいところなんですけどもなんと今回この地蔵ちゃんを
入った以上に準備しましたーーーで増産これ何人居るの
123452大寸自体のリズムを山を準備しました
でカラーが3色あるらしくてこちらの青い子が開くはピンクがベビーちゃんってこちら
の白い粉がスノー
23種類いるんですけども今回なぜこの際両技術も準備したかと言いますと
新
するってすごいですよ是非ともこの目で見てみたいんですけどもたっくさん1戦進化さ
せればええ的に凄いんじゃないかとにちょっとユーチューバー的な思考を考えた上で
托鉢見させていただきましたいわゆる今日はですねこの太陽ノイズ僕がガチで進化する
とこのぜひ見てみたいと思いますあの可能性は誰が苦手なんだよ
ちゃんと全員育てられるか不安なんですけども愛でがんばるぞ6
ます出会い後も行きましているずつ上げていきましょう
まずは軽装こっちゃいますのあらまぁ何なもの方あ
4日
映画お前ですねズーニー2子だから仲良くするなどさすがを開けます
食べちゃったーーーー
中抜きだよああ
[音楽]
ををっ
米激乳しか言わないよの号アンドレスああああああほっちゃんと待ってるね目がか弱い
ちょっとみんな上げていきましょう
me
病気によってん
全員たしておりました何でも何度全滅別の目が赤いぞ
なんだわー
あーあると思っちゃうのが今あぁ
会えずみんな怒ってしまいました所で宇宙から来たらしいんでたぶんこの図2ウェイ
生命体との遭遇によりちょっと威嚇してるらしいです
この後もなってちゃったんでしょ小泉なぁの僕のことを警戒しないようにしましょう
ねぇあああーさー
構成しました今ならすぐ出せてくればぁうーん
どうぞいやー
名前この後ちょっとしんどいのはいじゃあけど赤ちゃんぜひとりあえず
地球に生まれたようですねどうぞ
赤ちゃんの時って何できますからこの子たちでちょっと説明されてみましょうか
頭の塔頭ことはそれに目の色とある
すごいバイバイ
ぼなぺっといい
山尾動作中に
遊びたい色を得られずも降って決定だよ
音色で何かあるっぽいすすめですね緑の時
熱するとエッピザネットじゃあフィルと反応するらしいですね
で紫色イベの時はユダ常ベルらしいですね
[音楽]
rar
寝ちゃったならずにどっちにこうすると寝ちゃいますねおやすみ
キーワード yuta や声をものまでしてくるらしいですねピントか
[音楽]
ぽいどはー次マネー
ようお前ら俺が始めそうだ
[音楽]
パソコン無視する難病じゃないの俺の名前ははじめだ
あああ
[音楽]
もうすげーそんな企業がなるなオラー
はっ肥後至らなくマルキュウグ兄さんなボーダー柄んじゃないぞ
オレンジ色だと右や左に殺さメロディを苦節タブの野望
[音楽]
ガッキーものっていうのは青いミドルみたいなぜってみましょうそう
騒がしい直れ体験開けるの赤ちゃんモードあなたがぜもう今のいろんなことできるので
もう会えてみてこのはちょっと次の瞬間までちょっと頑張ってヨシヨシしてあげ
ましょう
あった
ben ん
王道車道さーんおいやばい一人どこが
うわすごいやつか ahkah を黄色に点滅するところでしんがですね
やばい必ず怠惰なともにおいてるって書いてありますかなれローマや
やっぱりシール白くなんかこういう日で応援してあげ応援がせると進化できないよ
応援しますかなら買われた
ああああああ
w
サーファー
あああーー
尻尾がいだー
これではない一人間もいいですねー赤ちゃんから多分子供になったのかな
を果たされることもちょっと雑感かって気にするなこれでまだ抱いて進化なんですけど
もてことはお前の進化するってことがあ
ご覧ん
おや早くあんたに続いて見直しんがショートしているぞこれ目が白くなったら僕が応援
しなきゃいけないらしいんで僕生ですねこれウエッ
うカバーああああ
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
6が税子供になりましたーーー
そんなここはを部門でなるんですねーよかったねみんな成長できてねー
ゴンはいというわけでせっかくみんなで進化できたのでさっきの女なお楽器モードが
あったらそれでちょっとみんなで一緒に演奏してみましょう
行くよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
みんなバラバラだねおとう
正解みたいなしゃべりなーみたいなはーい
うえおかきく傾向
ああああああ
[拍手]
良く見えましたーーーはいと読み上げる月9月この小川たちと遊びに行きましょう
そして早くお皿になるんだぞ
入った
はっ法要は細さがフォア
新カラー水面へ下げてガンバレ
ああ
がんばれー
ムンムンなに良い風あり外交
わー
[拍手]
[音楽]
わー
ねええええ
氷見が本当の姿なのねぇぞちゃん待てよ
この子が新華社ってことはここの私も進化するってこと
they シンガー食べずに家豆腐がみんな進化しますいい流れ
26らになるんだ
[拍手]
うわぁ
レバー
[拍手]
あー
[音楽]
をちょっと女うぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー things もんだああ
nao
書いただけで目ずいいみずほが税進化しました
小川ザインタレップのはなかったねー
いいした
アヌ rb
ああああ
[音楽]
さあさあ
me
示し火事えーい
[音楽]
e re
yeah 終わるどうしまったんだ水をがみんな下向いています
twice なんかめっちゃ喋ってるしいい
ダーヌー説明書を読むと
ちゃんと育てないと損いいなることがあるらしいでございます4スター縫うとジョン e
0 ce ねっのんぬー
何でも心とのしちゃったらいい
あああああっは
[拍手]
あー読みなりましたねよしこの調子でみんな助けていきましょう
じゃあ
うわぁ of the
方向すごい自力で復活するんだ
yeah yeah
ん
ブーブーぞそれ
はじめしゃちょー
[拍手]
終わらどうどうしてああマイラーだからただ真似づらくて本当にの得ることになります
ねこれ入れさらになんかゲームできるみたいですよ大人になると
へのゲームモードなんですけどもみずほちゃんたちの胸のランプの色に合わせて動かさ
なきゃいけないみたいなんです緑だと横に振る
フィールド縦に振る赤なら拍手を聴かせるらしいです
俺たち国境通ってるねふたり同然でもできる
んですよねー
まじかんはい水色でやって皆さん入っ
[音楽]
あたわっ
黄色は食べにくるん
いん
これで性が落ちらがんだっ
ね横に入れる
[拍手]
[音楽]
この子だけ男女の本でたね一人いくら何かそれじゃあこれをもう1回一人でやってみ
ましょうそう
nuvi でで横に振るあとは縦にたちが拍手
[音楽]
聞い色た手にする
多分喜びました上ですねちょっと大人になるとできることを振るんですけどさらにまだ
あるらしいですよ
ダンスダンスモードですね音や音楽に合わせてダンスするらしいです早速適当には学
流してみましょう
宮瀬スター
me
[音楽]
p 主です
または自由なそれははんだず自分で音がするなぁ
すごいを飛ぶのってる気がするわなんだけど変えもう見え出しそうでなによりでござい
ますねー
はいというわけで dion チャージャーを順次に無事を取るんですけどやってき
ましたーー
実際にこの形を変えて進化するっなかったと思う
本当に衝撃を受けましたーっ
寝放置したり汗やさんとしなかったりするとくれちゃってゾンビ涙もう本当にすごい
なって思いました
はいちょっと今までになかっただいますはいごめんね今までナイフだと思うのでみな
さんぜひ水もで遊んでみてください詳しい情報はどんな a 欄にございません猛獣が
発売なのでぜひに水本なまで進化させてみてください
じゃあ
[音楽]
car
me
あっはぁ